las complejas tensiones diplomáticas
entre marruecos y españa han provocado
una nueva crisis en la frontera sur de
europa marruecos escudo europeo contra
la migración africana maneja a su antojo
el flujo migratorio en función del ánimo
de sus relaciones con su socio españa
cuando rabat está contento cierra con
mano dura el paso fronterizo de los
enclaves españoles de ceuta y melilla
pero cuando el rey marroquí mohamed
sexto se enfada eleva la presión jugando
con la carta migratoria siempre como
presidente del gobierno de españa' he
creído firmemente que marruecos es un
país socio es un país amigo de españa y
así debe seguir siéndolo el cuidado de
nuestras relaciones ha formado parte
desde siempre de la política exterior
española también de mi gobierno y así
debe seguir siendo el pretexto del nuevo
pulso diplomático la autorización
española por motivos humanitarios para
el ingreso en un hospital español del
líder del frente polisario saharaui
brahím ghali para ser tratado de kobe 19
para rabat se trata de una ofensa
desleal cuyas consecuencias deben ser
asumidas el frente polisario de
desde hace décadas la independencia del
sáhara occidental' anexionado por
marruecos tras la retirada de españa en
1975 un conflicto entre el grupo armado
y el reino marroquí que volvía a
estallar el año pasado tras el
estancamiento de las negociaciones con
naciones unidas el castigo la mayor ola
migratoria de la historia reciente una
situación que preocupa también a europa
austin por ncn now lo más importante
ahora es que marruecos siga
comprometiéndose a evitar las salidas
irregulares y que los que no tienen
derecho a quedarse sean devueltos de
forma ordenada y efectiva por guardiola
en efectivo
richard por su posición estratégica
españa quiere mantener relaciones
positivas con su vecino del sur y socio
comercial marruecos